feature toggles can improve the workflow of your
development team, and lead to quicker software
delivery, Frederick osburgh from unleashed
will show you how feature toggles can help you.
Alright, so I brought with me, a friend of mine
here today to help to introduce you to feature
toggles. He is a brilliant engineer, and he's
the creator of unleash, which is the largest
open source solution for feature flagging
on GitHub. And I'm really excited to have
him here today to help explain feature toggles.
So welcome, Eva. And thank you for being here.
Thanks for having me. Yeah, it's my pleasure. I
was curious, just to kick this off. You've been
in the feature toggle game for quite some time
now. And I just wonder, what prompted you to start
feature toggling? And what was kind of the trigger
to make this happen and create this? The system?
Yeah, thanks for asking that. Actually, I started
on the leash or exploring feature toggling concept
back in 2014. And, and my kind of my goal or the
mission, or the reason for starting with that is
that I deeply care about develop proficiency. And
I was working as a tech lead and a team back then,
and, and we had already kind of automated how
we release software to an environment, all our
environments. So we had kind of the deployment
pipeline all set up, and we could in theory,
release whenever we wanted. And in our team,
we had also decided to do weekly sprints,
because we wanted to kind of have this
extreme focus and ship features all the time.
Because it makes sense. And also, we wanted to
kind of learn all all the time. But I saw that we
often fail to do releases every week, we couldn't
kind of ship software every week. And it bugged
me a lot, because we ended up with all these
feature branches, long running feature branches.
And it actually was quite hard to manage
these feature branches, because there was
a lot of changes. And I was kind of, you know,
when you're working on a larger feature, take
some time to write that code and get it right and
test it a bit and get some feedback on it. And,
and it feels like when you're pushing something
to production, it needs to be like perfect,
because you actually kind of presenting it to real
users out there. And, and for me, this bugged me
a lot, because they ended up us holding different
feature branches back in kind of separate kind of
local branches or test environments and stuff
like that. But they were never merged. And we
kind of postponed a lot of the learning. Right?
And, and for me this, this was a nightmare. And
I felt like my it was kind of cognitive
overload. And I thought that there has to
be better ways we should, we should try to
ship some code all the time in smaller chunks,
but but hide them from the users instead. And this
was when I started learning more about trunk based
development. And there were certain techniques to
kind of succeed with trunk based development. And
one of the techniques that a lot of people talked
about was feature toggles, or feature flags. And
I really loved that idea. And at this time,
there was a couple of other open source
solutions for this as well. But usually, they
were kind of tied to a specific framework,
or they were kind of very static, that it
was just a file in your app. And you could
kind of change the toggle, but there was less
of a dynamic built into it that I really wanted.
And this is why I started looking into creating
something like in Asia, I really wanted something
that could allow me to do trunk Base Development
divider features into smaller chunks. Even though
that complete feature was not releasable.
The end user still wanted to have the ability
to ship the code to production, just to get some
learnings like does it really make sense? Does
it work with production data is the firewall open
all of that kind of things that we developer care
about, but also that then I can know that a small
portion of the feature is done. And I can start
thinking of the next small portion of the feature
instead of thinking about everything all the time.
So just curious for the people that don't
know what is trunk base development. So
trunk base development is a very popular technique
these days is kind of opposite to more like a Git
flow where you use branches for everything. So
the idea is that you mainly work on the trunk or
the master branch or the main branch, you try
to kind of all the time commit directly to that.
That trunk branch is so that you never kind of
having long running feature branches in parallel.
This means that you you have all have
developers in the team collaborating
on the same code base instead of having local
copies of the code base in different states?
Right? Isn't that dangerous, though? Couldn't
you like easily get something into the master
branch that isn't completely tested? Or
doesn't work? 100% yet, or Yes, exactly. And
this is why you need feature toggles, because
then you use a feature toggle to wrap that code
so that you make sure that it's not exposed
before the code is ready to be exposed.
Right. So tell me a little bit more about that
kiss. Just curious to know how that works,
actually. Yeah, so so that kind of a feature
toggle is actually a very simple technique,
when you think about it, it's just kind of a small
if statement that you've wrapped the new code in.
And only if that feature toggle kind of evaluates
the true, we should evaluate the new code. If not,
we should use the old code. So basically, you
can think of it like you're you're replacing
the branches in your repository,
with branches in your code instead.
And this has, adds a lot of benefits. So it
means that when you're using a tool like unleash,
you can start then namak, Li changing who gets
access to a feature based on certain criterias in
a running application in production, so you don't
have to get the redeploy or anything like that.
Interesting. And this allows you to test early in
production, you can verify the new thing you're
working on, even though it's not completely
finished yet, you can test it on yourself,
and only enable it for your user in a
production environment, tested with real data,
make sure that the little part that you've already
built actually works the way you intended to work.
Right. So you have something
that's not completely finished,
and you hide it behind the flag
so that it's not turned on,
before you're actually ready to turn it on. But
you're continuously putting that into the master
branch so that you don't end up having multiple
different states. That could clash in the future.
Exactly. And, and working like this allows the
team to really collaborate on the code base,
and means that everyone will see your changes
very fast, because it's safe to kind of
just commit directly to the trunk and have that
directly in and share between the developers, it
means that you can basically refactor your code.
And it's hard because there will not be kind of
some new feature on a different feature branch
that is not yet complete that you have to wait for
before you can do this huge refactoring session.
So there is a ton of benefit of working this way.
Amazing is what about drawbacks? Like? Nothing
is completely 100%. Perfect. So just curious,
are there any drawbacks to using
feature toggles? Yes, of course. And
if you think about like a feature toggle is is
kind of technical debt by nature, because you are
having different version often of feature or
the code itself, you have two implementations
of something in your code base. So obviously, you
would not want to have that for a very long time.
But it really makes sense when you are kind of
trying out new ideas or working on a new feature,
or something like that, that really makes sense
to kind of encapsulate that in a feature toggle.
But we should also be a bit careful, because
if you're just adding feature toggles,
but never taking them away, allowing multiple
code paths to coexist in the code base, that
can be actually quite dangerous down the road.
Because usually developers which team they might
quit from your company. And it could be kind of
like, down the road, you can end up in a situation
where you have a lot of feature toggles, but
you're not sure if you can turn them off anymore,
will that work? Will your application still
work? So you're kind of really depend on a
certain state have that toggle. And when it
comes to that situation, it's really about
time to start cleaning up that and remove the dead
code and make sure that you only kind of execute
the code that you really want to execute. And
there is other things there as well. And that is
a will having a lot of features bill also make
your code a bit harder to test actually because
you will need to kind of test you will have a lot
of different parts through your application give
based on what what the state of the feature toggle
will be if it's on or off or maybe it's a certain
variant might not just be on but it could be
divided between different implementations.
And then you certainly communist that should you
test All the permutation of all the toggles in
your application, maybe not. But you should at
least try to test the important ones, at least
with kind of automated tests and make sure that
what most of your user will, will end up seeing
in production should obviously we are tested
cobalt, and then there is a discussion if you're
also need to test all the different feature toggle
states, maybe maybe not, it depends a bit on which
type of application you're working on, I guess.
Right? So I'm actually curious about this. Because
when we're talking about deploying
multiple times a day, or, or getting
to a point where we're releasing all the time,
then obviously, a big part of that is having
automated tests. So you know that the code that
you release is actually working and functional,
when you push it out to production. But when
you're relying on a third party program,
and I know that a lot of the feature
talking solutions that exist today
are like traditional SAS platforms, you
set up your feature toggles there, and,
and you kind of use them in your code, and
you have to communicate with them. So you're
kind of have this external dependency. And as you
mentioned, that could be really hard to test. So
how can you get around that? How can you make
sure that you can test your code thoroughly,
even when you have a third party that you have
to rely on? Yeah, and that's actually one of
the benefits of choosing an open source platforms
such as unleash, because you can, you can actually
just take the unleash open source, and that
will be 100% protocol compliant with the SDK,
the enterprise will obviously give you some
more features. But you can take that and run
this as part of your integration testing, if you
really want to test the interaction with a leash.
And then you can just kind of pre configure that
open source instance, to be in a certain state so
that you can kind of test all the states that are
important to you. A lot of our SDK is also allow
you to do testing, for instance, the Java SDK has
a built in kind of fake ilish implementation where
you can kind of set the toggles in certain states.
But that's typically more useful in more like
unit test cases where you kind of are building
unit tests for us more portion of the code.
But usually, that doesn't make sense. When you
start integration testing or end to end testing,
then you often want to actually have some
kind of third instance running that is
replicating what you're doing. And that's
quite easily Tashi, with Alisha would say,
interesting. And anything more you feel like,
it's important to talk about when we're,
we're talking? Yeah, I think I think there is a
lot of things. And I'm sure that you will cover
a lot of the important topics in this course. So
I'm super happy that you're doing this course.
I think in the end, there is obviously
drawbacks with everything, there is
nothing that comes for free. But as long as
we kind of handle those drawbacks and take
care of the technical debt, and make sure that
we have some processes to also clean up that
we set aside maybe a day a month or something
to kind of validate the toggles were using Are
they still relevant? I think the the benefits
kind of outweighs the drawbacks. And I see that
teams starting to adopt feature toggles or wanting
to run with the trunk based development process
seems to gain a lot of value out of using feature
toggles. And to me it's kind of an eye opener
has seen in in in real life, how it's accelerated
the learnings from the software we're working on,
and how we can safely release all the time in
small chunks, get feedback on those changes. Are
they working? Are they doing what we intend them
to do? And kind of bit by bit building out complex
features, which is a it's an awesome capability to
have to be honest. Yeah, it's sounds amazing. So
I'm really excited that you're here. And were able
to give us this kind of introduction to feature
toggling. So I want to thank you for taking time
to do that. And now hopefully, we're going to be
ready to dive into the code and start implementing
that on our own, which is going to be exciting.
Thanks for having me. You're welcome. Alright, so
we heard a little bit about what feature toggles
are and how you can use them. So now we're
going to get into a little bit more. And I
want to stress them in the most basic form. A
feature toggle is just an if else statement.
So what you could do is you could have a flag
in your code that says whether or not something
is are off. And obviously, if you're diligent,
and you're able to remember to turn this flag
on and off, when you're developing, or you're
loading it from some kind of configuration file,
that can be enough to just get the ball rolling
and get started, because it means that you can go
ahead and merge in your code at any point in time.
So what we'll do is we'll take a look at how we
can perform this and how we can implement it into
the Free Code Camp code base. So let's get to it.
Alright, so here we have the Free Code Camp
website. And it's running locally on my machine.
So let's just take a quick moment and go through
what's here. As you can see, we're at the landing
page right now. And we have this text in the
middle, and the call to action that says get
started, it's free. And if we scroll down, we have
an S seen in section, we have an alumni section.
And in the end, here, we have the certification
section. So that's basically the structure of
the landing page. Now, let's go to the top. And
we're just going to focus on this part right here.
And what we want to do is want to take this
section right here, and we're going to swap it
out with a new section. So we'll take a look at
the code, we'll take a look at the new section.
And then we'll take a look at how we can use a
flag to toggle this on or off. So here we are
inside of the Free Code Camp code base. And
we're inside of index js. Now, the landing
top component here is the existing component that
corresponds to what we just saw on the main page.
And we have this landing top v two here, which
is the new design that we want to go ahead and
implement. So what we'll do is we'll uncomment
this. And we'll scroll down a little bit. And we
have a piece of code here that we're also gonna
comment in. And then we'll comment this out,
just so we can see the changes that
we make. So if we head back to the
and now we can see that we have the
new component in place of the old one,
we still have one issue that when we have the
header up here, that is a universal header.
But we chose to include it in the new
design in the this component. So what
we'll go ahead and do is we'll go back to
the code, or find the header components.
And we'll take the universal now. And for now,
we'll just go ahead and comment that out. And
if we head back to the browser, now, we should see
it update. And here we have the new landing page.
So what we'll look at now is hiding this behind a
flag, so that we can easily toggle it on or off.
Let's head back to the code. And the first
thing we'll do is we'll go ahead and create a
new file and source both flags. Yes. And in here,
we'll create a constant called new design on and
we'll set it initially to be false. Now, what
we'll do is we'll go back to our landing page.
And we'll change this because it's not good to
have a bunch of uncommented code around and we
want this to be flexible, we need to find a way to
be able to display either this component or this
component based on the flag. So let's go ahead
and import the new design on flag. And I get some
help there from my auto importer. So now we have
the new design on imported. And we'll use this
to conditionally render one thing or the other.
So we'll say const landing page component
or landing top components Be precise. And
we'll say new design on and if it's on,
we want to render this part right here. Otherwise,
and we'll denote that with a colon where you want
the old landing page
components Now we'll put it in.
Right here. Basically, we're saying if it's on,
give me this part, if it's off, give me this part.
And then we're taking the value there. And we're
rendering it inside the main container. Let's go
ahead and see what we get. Now in the browser, if
we head back, now we have the old landing page.
But we're still lacking the universal navigation.
So let's go ahead and fix that as well.
So we're going to index TSX in the
header. And we'll comment this back.
And we'll do the same thing
here. So we'll say new design on.
And we'll use that to render the universal NAB.
So navigation equals new design on then we want
nothing. Otherwise, we want
the universal navigation.
So remember that the new design has the navigation
built in. So we don't want anything in that case.
If it's not on, then we want to render it
because it belongs with the old components.
So if we hit save on that,
and go back to the code,
or the browser, we now have the navigation
back as well. So what this allows us to do,
is we can go back to the code, and we can go
to our flag. And we can flip this to true.
And now we have one central state that controls
whether or not we show one component or the other.
Now we're soon getting to the really cool part.
And the ultimate goal that we're trying to areas
that we want to be able to quickly merge
things back into the master branch and get
things into production, without having to worry
about whether or not it's 100% functional,
because we can make the improvements as we go
along and hide the feature from the user base
until it's 100% complete. Now, what
we have now, a flag that we can click
on or off in our code, it's gonna work
but it's a little bit brittle. You know,
if you have a flag that you have to
have a conscious relationship with,
and you have to know whether or not
it's on or off, when you push your code,
it adds mental overhead. And it just it's
it's one more thing to keep track of.
And what could be really dangerous if you actually
forget that you turn it on, on something that's
not finished. And you inadvertently could push out
something that's unfinished to your customers or
users of your hobby project or whatever it
is that you have running in production. So
we need to do something to make sure that that
can happen. So we'll jump back to the code.
And we'll take a look at how we can make
this flag a little bit more dynamic.
So right now is set to true. And what I
want to do is I want to use the process EMV
node environment. And I actually want
to say that if it is in development,
then I want new design to be on.
And if I hit save on that, we should be able
to see the new design still, because we are in
development, we are running the node process
here in development, it's not in production.
So let's go ahead and verify that and say that
if we want the new design to be on in production,
we have to be running process in production.
And now you can see we get the old design
or the current design. So that's gonna help us
because that means that when we actually deploy
this, if we have this set to development, we don't
have to worry about this making it into production
provided that we are specifying the correct
parameters when we are running the process.
Alright, so one of the pitfalls and we kind
of mentioned that when we were doing the
environment variable is that if you're just having
a fly in your code, it can be quite easy. to risk
not remembering to turn it back off again,
like you're working on a feature, something's
happening, maybe the babies are crying, or you're
burning your food, or you have to run your minds
elsewhere, and you come back in, you forget that,
you put the flag on, and you commit something,
and maybe you, maybe you get it into production,
like, obviously, you'll have some other gods,
right? You're a good developer, you have people
reviewing your code, and someone's gonna catch it,
I'm sure. But what if they don't like, it
can happen, should happens. And you do have
run this risk if you're not using environment
variables, and you have the flag in your code. But
there are easy ways to get around that. Now,
another thing that you might experience is that
you actually reduce the benefits of feature
toggling when you're putting it in the code,
because one of the big benefits is that you can
actually use the configuration from an external
location to toggle the feature on and off in
your code without actually doing another deploy.
And like that's the real magic, not the stuff that
you can actually merge it in. That's good. That's
nice. But the real magic happens when you can
actually control your application from an external
source. And you don't have to do a new deploy in
order to, in order to get a new version of your
code out there, you can just flip a switch, and
there's another version of your code that will run
live in production. So think about that, like
you have a product manager or something that
is launching a new feature. And he's at home,
and it's Friday night. And you're trying to
launch a new feature, because you always launch on
Fridays, right? That's, that's a golden rule. But
what if something goes wrong? Like he has to call
up his developers, they have to figure out what
went wrong. And then they have to deploy a new
version? Well, what if he could just push a button
and go on with his weekend, and then on Monday, we
can go back to trying to figure out what's wrong.
That's the real magic. And that's what we're going
to take a look at in the next section. Alright,
so what we'll do now is we'll focus
on taking this flag that we have
inside of our code, and we want
to move it to an external service,
so that we can toggle the feature on or off,
and without having to redeploy our code.
Now, the way we'll do that is we'll use a service
called Jason min, which allows you to host Jason
in the cloud, and you get an API URL that you
can use to retrieve the Jason configuration.
So let's go ahead and create our Jason
configuration. And we have the Ben creation
screen in front of this right here. So we'll go
ahead and put in a Jason configuration here. And
we'll start with the open curly brackets, and a
key that says new design. And we want the default
value to be false for now. Also, we have to make
sure that we put this from private to public bin
so that we are able to get the configuration
without an API key, just for testing purposes.
Of course, if you're running this in production,
or you want a more robust setup, obviously,
you want to have a proxy in between that can take
care of hiding your API key on the server side.
But for now, we're going to keep it public so that
we can easily retrieve the information and then
we'll take a look at how to use a proxy later
on. So let's go ahead and hit create on that.
And you can see now we have a access URL down
here in the bottom of the screen. We'll copy that.
And just to make sure that this is working,
they sit in. And here you can see we have the
Jason configuration. Alright, so now that we
have that, we can jump into the code and start
putting it together the pieces that we need
in order to retrieve the configuration.
Alright, so here we are back in the code. And
we are in a component called default layer,
which is a component that wraps
all of the other components in
this project. And this is where we'll add
the logic for retrieving the configuration
and it will use it to supply the configuration
down to the components that need it. Now this
is something I would normally use hooks for. But
since we are using class components here, this is
the method that we are going to work with. So to
begin with, let's go ahead and add a constructor
And we'll go ahead and take some
props. And we'll say, super props.
None, we'll initialize our state. And we
want the state to have a ready property.
And we're going to add a new design.
That's going to be our initial states. Now,
next up, we'll add a fetch feature toggle on
figuration. And inside of here, we are going to
get the configuration from our Jason
bin. So let's go ahead and say fetch.
And now we need to go ahead and retrieve
the URL, we'll go ahead and copy that.
And we'll paste that in here. And then we'll
say, we'll get the result. And if the result
is okay, so if it's 200, then we want to return
press Jason. And then we'll take that Jason data.
And we'll say if they get ready, is
false. And we'll say this set state
ready is true. And new design equals JSON dot
new design. Otherwise, we'll say this set state.
And we'll make sure we put this in the
right place. And we want to return here.
So if ready is not false, we will just want to put
the new design through the Jason new design value.
Let's go ahead and hit save on that.
And then we need to add this here on the
states. This we're referring to the class.
And let's go ahead and throw
an error here. If we fail to
get the configuration, and we'll
just catch and log it out for now.
Alright, so let's go ahead and make sure that we
call this function. And we'll go ahead and do that
in the component did mounts, they'll say this
fetch feature toggle configuration. And then I
think we set the new design to be false in the
adjacent bin. Let's just check that quickly.
We did. Though, we'll clip this to true, just
to see that we are getting the expected results.
When we retrieve our configuration, we
can also inspect the network requests. So
let's go ahead and just log out
the states in our render function.
And then we'll head over to the browser,
and we'll check out the behavior.
Alright, so let's go ahead and
open up our developer tools.
And we can see that in our console, we have two
objects. The first one is the first state. So
we set new design to true and ready to false in
the initial state. And then we have the updated
state here where a new design is false and red
is true. So we get new design from the JSON bin,
and we set the property to be false. We can
also verify this by checking the Network tab.
So let's hit refresh here. And that's
gonna capture all of the network requests.
And we can see in the top pair that we have
in the request, it's asking towards this URL,
and the response is the base and then content.
Alright, so now that we have that, let's focus
on getting this data into the components
that need it. So we'll head back to the code.
Now we need to pass this state down to the header
because we need to hide the universal navigation
based on the flag And then we also need to get
it into the landing page component. So let's
take a look at this render function here. And we
can see that we have a lot of links, you can see
we have the header here. Let's go ahead and pass
new design here and say this state new design.
And then we are going to have to do a little
bit more work in order to get it into the
landing page component because we are rendering
children here, which is basically the React way
of saying that anything that is put inside of this
component, when it's rendered, all of its children
are going to be fit inside of here. So we
can't access the children at the time they are
initialized, which means that we can't actually
pass the children props, or properties. So what
we need to do is we need to go ahead and recreate
the children. So we'll do react children map.
And then we'll pass the
children as the first argument.
And the second argument will be a function. And we
will receive the first or the child's as the first
argument. And inside of this function, we want
to take the child and we want to clone it and
decorated with the new parameters that we want
to pass down. So let's do react, clone element.
And make sure we put return in front of that.
And we'll say child, and we'll say new design,
this state your design. Alright. So that should
take all of the children, loop over them.
And take each child make a clone and pass
it these properties or this property.
So let's go ahead and find the index page
components. That will do index page. Now
let's go in here in the index TSX part of the
index page. And that's going to be the child
that we're passing the prop two,
so need to accept props here.
And since this is a TSX file, we're going
to be good citizens and create an interface.
And we'll say new design is a Boolean.
And let's say page is a string.
And let's go ahead and pass the props here. And
then we'll take the properties which is an object.
And we'll pass them along to the landing
page here. Let's open up that components.
And we'll accept the parameter here.
And let's go ahead and log this out.
So now if we head over to the browser, and we open
up the developer tools, we should be able to see
a console log that says false. And we do right
down here. So that means that we have successfully
moved the data down to the landing
page component. So let's go ahead and
go back to our code. And we'll swap out the
new design on here with the new design property
up here. So we'll do this
instead of our built in flag.
And we are going to go ahead and do
the same in the header components.
Let's go ahead and find that which is up here.
And we are going to say instead of new
design on we'll say this box, new design.
And currently, this is set the poll, so
we expect our old landing page to return,
which it does. And here we also have the
header just a little bit slow rendering there.
Alright, so to round up the section, we
want to make sure that we can use the J
S bin configuration to control which design is
running on this site. And in order to do that,
we need to make a few final changes to the code.
So let's go ahead and jump back in. And you can
see we already have built the functionality to
fetch the configuration and to update the state.
And now we need to make sure that we're able to
get the new configuration once the configuration
changes in the JSP. And the way we'll handle them
is we're going to set up an interval. And that
interval is going to refetch the configuration
every five seconds. So we'll go ahead and set an
interval here. And the function that's going to
run is this fetch feature toggle configuration.
And as we said, we want that to run every five
seconds. So with that in place, now, we just need
to go down here, and we need to make a change to
this URL. Because we want the latest configuration
every time we fetch against this. Otherwise, we
would get the first version and not the updated
one. So we need to make sure that we put on
latest at the end here. And since we set up
an interval here, we also want to make sure
that we go ahead and clear that interval,
should the components are not. There, if we hit
save on that, we can head back to the browser.
And as you can see, we still have the original
view here. But if we head over to our J spin,
and we hit edit, and we flip this state to
true. And we go ahead and update the Ben.
Now if we head back to our website, we have the
new design in place, because we're now controlling
the feature using the J S bin configuration. And
there you have it. And honestly, this is easily
one of my favorite things about feature toggling
having the ability to just flip a flag like this.
And then seeing the changes instantly reflected
in your website running in production.
I mean, that's incredible. Having the ability
to release code with the confidence that if
anything goes wrong, you can just turn it off.
That's incredible. It gives you so much safety.
And it makes you so much more efficient. As a
developer, of course, you'll still write tests,
you'll still take the precautions that you need to
take. But just having that safety net, just having
that level of certainty that if something goes
wrong, you can just turn it off, makes it a joy
to ride and release code because you're
eliminating the element of risk. And honestly,
that's like magic to me. Alright, so let's talk
about some of the drawbacks of using this method
of implementation. So earlier, we talked
about the fact that if you're using built in
feature flags into your code, you miss out on
some of the benefits of using feature toggles.
Now you can get some of those back
by using an external configuration.
But if you did, like we did, now,
you have to be extremely careful,
because when you're working with raw Jason,
and that's controlling your application,
it can be a little bit brittle, because Jason
is a data format. And you need to adhere 100%
to the format in order for it to work. So
there is a very little margin for error. Now,
in Jason bin, luckily, we have some protection. So
we can't just put in any arbitrary value and hit
update because it will say that it's invalid
Jason and we won't be allowed to update.
But what we can do is we can put in something
like this, where we put in a string, which is
valid Jason, but we put in the string false.
So maybe we were doing something quickly, maybe
we didn't realize that you have to use True or
False without quotes for it to be a Boolean.
But the result now is that we still have the the
sign that we started with so we didn't actually
So we make the update that we wanted to, we have
to go back here. And we have to change this now to
say, balls, and then hit the update button again.
And now we get the result that we expected.
So you can see that you have to be
very precise in your instructions. And it's not
something that you would let someone that's non
technical in there. So you would have to
kind of keep this in the developer family,
which could be fine. But you need to make sure
that you are being vigilant when you're working
with this stuff. So that's one thing. Another
thing might be that, as cool as this functionality
that we've implemented is, and as powerful
as it is, it's still a little bit limiting.
The, you might want to give certain users
access to the feature in production.
Maybe you want to do a gradual rollout that rolls
out to percentage of your users maybe want to
have some metrics on who are getting access to
this feature or not. Or maybe you just want to
be able to connect from different applications
maybe have more than one application. And they're
in different programming languages. And you have
to write these bindings for each application.
And that's when you kind of start looking for
an vendor of these things, because now we're
talking about hours of investing into developing
something homegrown. And there might be better or
more robust alternatives out there that you can
use for free. And that's what we're going to look
in to in the next section, we'll look at some paid
actors, we'll look at some free actors. And then
we'll dive into the product that I'm working
on, which is called unleash. Right, so we need
want to do more than just basic feature tarwin,
like rolling out to a percentage of your users
having certain users get access in production,
getting metrics, connecting multiple applications,
you quickly find yourself wanting to
look for a vendor. And I firmly believe
that looking for a vendor in these kinds of
situation is a good idea. Because every line
of code that you write yourself, you're going to
have to maintain and code is now in my mind, it's
a living product, it lives over time, you're going
to have to have a conscious relationship to it.
It's not like you write it once, and then
you're done, you're going to find that you
have to work with this code again and again and
again. And you have to either add capabilities
that weren't there before, or you're going to have
to fix something that isn't working as intended.
So with that said, let's take a look at some of
the vendors that you can use for feature totally.
And there are a number of actors
in the space that you can utilize.
And I'm not going to go into detail on them
here, but I will mention them. So you can
make up your own mind. You have platforms like
LaunchDarkly split, dyo, WVU, VWO, CloudBees,
Optimizely, and harness, which basically,
they operate this traditional SAS platforms.
And then you have some open source alternatives
such as GitLab, rollout, flipper, and unleash,
which is the solution that I'm working on.
Now, which solution should you choose? Well,
I'm not going to tell you that. And first of
all, because I'm severely biased, and obviously,
I want you to use unleash. But secondly, it really
depends on your needs. The vendors mentioned here
all have their strengths and weaknesses. And they
all have their unique development philosophy.
And I will say this, though, when you're choosing
a vendor, I think it's also important to take a
look at the development philosophy and
make sure that it matches your own.
So with that said, I'm going to tell you a few
words about the development philosophy at unleash.
So first and foremost, we are huge fans of
open source unleashed started as an open
source product, and it still is one today. And
95% of our code is freely available on GitHub.
And if that serves your use
case, you can use that for free.
No problem. And what's great about open source is
that if you have a problem that we can easily fix,
you can submit a issue and if we tell you that
we can fix the issue because we have other
priorities, you can always submit a pull request
and fix it yourself. Or you can fork the code and
make your own adjustments as you see fit. And
in today's development climate, we believe that
this flexibility is a key factor in order
to succeed in bringing tools to developers,
developers are curious beings, we like to see
how things work. We'd like to feel in control.
At least I know I do. And, yeah, I think
that's important. Though. Secondly,
we believe strongly in privacy. We don't
think that solutions that claim ownership
over organizations data is a sustainable way
going forward. And this is why most of our
SDKs are extremely privacy focused, we do all
of the evaluation of feature toggles locally,
to avoid leaking data back to our system.
So if you're using our paid, hosted version,
none of the data actually leaves your application,
it all stays in inside of your ecosystem. And if
you're using open source, you control the
back end anyway. So there's no issue there.
So with that said, I'm going to take you
through the architecture of unleash. And
we're going to go ahead and
see how unleash can help you.
Before we get started setting up the unleash
open source, let's go ahead and take a brief
look at the architecture just we know what we are
working with. And we'll start by taking a look
at the SDK 's. And SDK stands for software
developer kit. And what it basically is,
is pre written code in a programming language
that handles the connection to the Unleashed API.
So you will use the SDK in your own application
and configure it to talk to the unleash API.
And then the SDK will go ahead and download the
feature token configuration at a given interval
that you can tune and it will store it locally in
memory. That means that you don't have to do an
API call every time you want to check if a
feature toggle this on or off, you're basically
doing the evaluation and the lookup in the cache
memory of your application. And that gives you a
lot of performance. And it also means that
none of your user data is ever shared back
with the unloose server, whether or not you're
using open source or using the hosted solution.
And let's talk about the API. The unleash API
is split into two parts. You have the Admin API,
which allows you to do changes to feature toggles,
add new ones, and update the future configuration.
And then you have the client API, which is one
that serves the unleash SDK case. And this API
is split from the Admin API, because it's
supposed to be really stable, rarely changed.
And you can create a specific API key, that's read
only. So that means that if you should lose your
API key for the client API that serves the SDK
as the attackers won't be able to use that to
actually make changes in the configuration. So
anything you can do and unleash, you can do via
an API call. So we have an admin interface
that we'll see later. But if you wanted to,
you could do everything with curl commands, or you
could wire up your CI pipeline to talk to unleash.
So let's talk about the proxy. So remember
earlier when we were talking about the J S bin
integration, and we said that we might want to do
this via a proxy. And one of the reasons for that
is the added security layer. So when you're
talking to API's, you usually want to limit
who has access to the API. And you do that by
generating a unique API key that will provide
access to the holder of this key. Now, when we're
working in the front end, or the client side,
whether it be a web application, or an native
app, like an Android or iOS application,
you generally want to keep the secrets out of this
area, because it's not a safe space. So what the
proxy provides is a layer between your client side
application and the Unleashed server that provides
secure server to server communication,
where you can safely store your API key.
In addition to the security of the API key, the
unleash proxy will only return evaluated toggles.
And this is information that's already
available in your source code. which is
free for everyone to look at, if they have access
to the developer tools and can inspect your code,
so you are reducing the amount of information
that's traveling to your front end to safe
information, so to speak. Aside from the added
security, you also get improved performance by
using the proxy. So the proxy can handle around
2000 requests per second. And it's really easy to
spin up and scale new instances of the proxy,
because it's just a stateless Docker container. So
that's going to give you an easy way to scale your
application by adding more proxies and connecting
them to the same unleash application. With that
said, let's go ahead and set up a local instance
of unleash and a local proxy, and start exploring
the possibilities of using feature toggles.
Okay, so now we're going to go ahead and get
started setting up unleashed open source on
our local machine. And in order to do that, we
are going to use a software called Docker. Now,
Docker is a way of taking something called Docker
containers, which are small virtual environments
that have all of the dependencies
needed to run a piece of software
and run that as a container on your machine. So
basically, you're running a small computer on
your computer, which has its own operating system,
and its own dependencies. And it's already bundled
for you so that you don't have to
set up your machine to replicate
these dependencies. And it's a really powerful
way to get started just running software,
if you want to try out new software on your
local machine. So if you don't have Docker,
make sure you go to docker.io. And you hit the
get started button up in the right hand corner.
And then just follow the instructions to set up
Docker on your machine. And then you should have a
mand called Docker. Once you're done that you can
run in your terminal. So when you've done that,
we are going to go ahead and open up the Unleashed
documentation and go to the deploy and manage tab.
And under Option One will have the option to
use Docker. So there'll be some commands here
that we are going to use. We modified them
slightly for this example, because I've already
set up some of this on my machine and I want to
do it completely from scratch. So we are going to
head over to our terminal and get started running
these commands in order to set up long leash.
Alright, so here we are in the terminal. And the
first thing we'll do is we'll go ahead and create
a network for Docker. So we'll write
Docker network, create unleash nets.
And that's going to give us a hash as a
confirmation that we created the network. And now
we'll go ahead and set up Postgres. So we'll have
this command right here, we'll say docker run. And
we are providing some environment variables. So
obviously, if you're running this in production,
you want to change the password, and make sure
that you choose something that's really secure.
But for this example, we are just gonna go with
the defaults here. And we'll start the postgres
on 5432, and we'll map it to 5001 on our local
machine. So if we start that, we should see the
postgres output, and right here we see that
it's ready to accept an actions in the bottom.
So now we can go ahead and open
up a new tab in our terminal
and we will use a Docker command
to start the unleased server.
So we'll do docker run. And we'll map that
to 4242 on our local machine, and we want to
make sure that we match the database host.
And the database port is going to be 5432.
So we hit Enter on that, that's going to start
up the unleash application. And now we can head
over to our browser and we can open a new
tab tab here, and visit localhost or 242.
And here we have the first screen that you get
to when you open up the address in the browser.
And as part of running the Docker container,
unleash will set up the database. And it will
run some migration and create all the tables.
And it will also create a default user. So once
you're here, you can go ahead and log in with
the following credentials. So that's going to be
admin, as the username and unleash for all as the
password to go ahead and input that and login.
And you're taken to the main application
interface. Now, there's not much period.
And we'll explore this in a second. But for now,
we want to continue with the setup. And we still
have to set up the proxy. And in order to do
that, we need to do a few things in the UI here.
So we'll go to the Configure drop
down. And we'll open up API access.
So in here, you can create and delete API keys.
And we also have the API URL readily available
that we need to supply when we are
setting up the proxy. We'll go ahead
and create our API token now. And we'll hit
this button in the upper right hand corner.
And that's going to trigger this dialog. And we're
going to fill out the name here. And we'll call
it proxy key. We're going to keep the token type
to client, because that means that this key will
be read only. So it's only going to be allowed
to read data. We'll keep the project settings
as it is and then we'll change the environment
to development. And once we have that,
we can create the token. And now we have
everything we need to set up the proxy.
In order to do that, we'll head back to the
documentation. And in the left hand side menu, we
have under unleash SDKs, the Unleashed proxy tab.
If we open that up and scroll a little bit down,
then we can see instructions on how to
run the unleash proxy. And we are going
to use this command right here. But I have
prepared it a little bit. So let's go and
head over to the terminal. And here we have
the command that is going to start the proxy.
So what we've done here is we've taken the API
token that we just created. And the way we did
that was we went to the UI. And we hit copy
on this to copy the token to our clipboard.
And then we went back to the terminal and we put
the token in here. That's the API token that we
created. Now, the unleash URL points to the local
instance of unleashed running on my machine.
And since I'm on Mac, I have to use host
Docker internal for the proxy to access this
port through the virtual environment. If
you're on Mac, sorry, Linux or Windows,
it's going to be slightly different. But I'm going
to include documentation on how to get that done.
So that you can follow along. In the top, we
have something called unleash proxy secret,
which is just a very thin layer of security.
Like I said before, anything that's exposed on
the client side is not really a secret. So the
main security of the proxy comes from the fact
that it takes the API key, and it hides it in
server to server communication. And it doesn't
give any other data out other than evaluated
toggles and information that already exists
in your source code. So while you
will put up a secret here that will
allow the clients that are connecting to the proxy
to read from the proxy, if they have the secret,
the main security is within the proxy itself. So
with that said, you can go ahead and start it.
And it's going to say that it's now listening
on port 3000. And if we want to go and check
if this is working, we can take this curl command
here and copy that and head back to the terminal.
paste this in a new terminal window,
and you can see that we get response
with an empty toggles array,
which is what we expect.
Okay, so now that we have the proxy running, let's
go ahead and take a quick tour of the application,
and then we'll create our first feature
toggle. So we're currently in the main view,
we will navigate to the project section. And here
we have the default project, which is the project
that we get for free when we start up. And this is
the only project that we have in the open source
version. But it should be enough for our use
case. If you open that up, we have a view that
gives you a little bit more information about
the project. And we're not going to go through
everything. But I want you to take note of
the environment section. If we head over here,
you can see that we have the default
enrollment enabled. And then we have
development and production as disabled. And this
will be more important later when we start to
do more advanced segmentation. And we want to
decide who gets access to a feature. And we can
segment that on environments as well. So
for now, we're just going to turn this on.
And we're going to head back to the overview here.
And we'll go ahead and we'll create our first
feature toggle. So in order to create a pitch
toggle, we just need to give it a unique name.
And we'll go ahead and hit create. And
then we are taken to the total overview.
Now, there's a lot of information here. But I
want us to focus on this part in the middle.
So see this traffic section right here. Notice
how it corresponds to the environments that we
turned on in the project. So since we turned on
production and development, we now have the option
to see traffic from those environments. And if
we scroll a little bit further down, we have a
strategy section. And this is an important concept
in unleash because strategies are really rules
that determine whether or not a feature should
be on or off. And you can add these rules to any
environment, and they will only be active in that
environment. So let's take a look at an example.
We'll go to the strategies section. And we want
to navigate to the development environment,
we don't want to add one to the default
environment. And I'll explain why in a second.
But let's go ahead and add the gradual
rollout to the development environment.
So what we see here is the configuration of
the strategy. And we can adjust this to be 25%.
And you can see that's reflected
in the execution plan here.
And it says that 75% of your user base
is included. So if we save the strategy,
now we can see that we have one strategy in the
development environment, but the environment is
still disabled. So in order for a strategy to
be executed, we need to turn on the environment.
And the difference between doing this and what
we just did in the Project Settings is that
when we set it in the project, we set a project
by setting or all of the feature toggles that
we create, that gives all feature toggles access
to these three environments. But what we're doing
here is we're saying, for this feature toggle,
we want the strategies in this environment
to execute. So it's a handy way to turn on
or off an environment or a feature toggle.
Now, what we can do is we can head over to our
terminal. And we can try the command again to
call against the proxy. And you can see that
we're getting the page toggle in the first call,
then we're getting in the emptier in the second.
And then we're getting the feature toggle again in
the subsequent calls. So what's going on? Well,
if we take a look at the configuration here,
we've set the strategy execution to be 75%.
Which means that three out of four calls, we
should get the feature toggle. And that's exactly
what's happening. So if we bump this up to 100%.
And we hit save, and we head back to the
terminal again. Now if we go ahead, and we
try to get the feature configuration, we should
get it every time. Alright, so how does this work?
How does the proxy now that we want to fetch the
configuration from the development environment?
Well, if you remember back to when we initialize
the proxy, remember the API token part here. Or in
here, we've specified the development environment
as part of the API token. And actually,
we configured that when we created the token. So
if we head back to the UI, and we go to the API
Access section, when you hit Create API token, you
have the ability here to change the environment.
So that determines which environment it's
going to fetch the configuration for.
Alright, so now we know enough to
implement this in a real application.
Alright, so we're back to the component that we
started with. And now we've taken it out of the
Free Code Camp codebase. And we moved it into a
create react app project, just to reduce some of
the mental clutter and overhead when we're working
with this. And we've done some modifications that
will use a feature toggle to turn on and off.
And we'll go ahead and take a look at that now.
So in the app js file, you can see what's
currently being rendered to the screen. And inside
of app, we have a conditional render component.
And based on the condition that is given, it's
either rendering the applet chatbot component, or
the app without chatbot component. So currently,
it's rendering this last component here. And you
can see these are defined in the same file. So
let's see what happens when we flip this to
true just to get the visual confirmation here.
And you can see now we have this chat
button in the bottom of the screen,
we can click that. And we can
type into the message box here.
And this is what we want to feature toggle.
So this is our feature. And we want to turn
it on for a subset of our users. So in
order to do that, let's go to the unleash
instance here. And we'll create a new
feature total. We'll call that chatbots.
And we'll go to the strategy section. And we'll
add a bungee to the development environment.
So we'll set it to be a gradual
rollout of 0% to begin with.
And then we will turn on the environments here.
From here, we can go ahead and start
connecting our application to unleash.
And we'll do that by using the unleash proxy
client or react. So we just need to follow the
instructions here. And we'll start by adding
the unleash proxy client to our project.
So open this up and add the proxy clients.
And then we can repair a little bit by taking
this part right here. And going back to
our project, and then we can paste this
in. And now we need to make sure that the conflict
is correct. So we'll swap this out with localhost
3000. And make sure we're on HTTP, the proxy key
is going to be let's go ahead and check that.
Some secrets are put that in as well. We'll
set the refresh interval to be five seconds.
And we'll change the app name to FCC play.
Though the environment here is not related to
the strategies that we talked about earlier,
this was actually in place before we added
strategy support. But the only thing
that affects where you are patching,
or which configuration you are fetching is the API
key and the configuration of that API key. Okay.
So with that said, we now have a config
that we are supplying to this flag provider.
And we should be able to add into our app
component and start using our feature flags.
So in here, we're going to grab a
few things from the proxy files.
So we'll import the use flag and use flags status.
And what we can do now is we can say enabled
equals US flag and then we need to pass the
digital name here. So let's
go ahead and make sure that
this is the actual name of the future tutorial.
And we can see that here. So that should be fine.
If we now head back, we can go ahead and See
his flag status
and want to grab bags ready from this object. So
if not bags ready, we are going to return a loader
just a simple loader now. Otherwise we'll use the
enabled flag to render the correct version. Let's
log this out as well after the flags ready
just to make sure we are triggering that
events. So if we go back to the browser,
and now we can open up our application.
And if we refresh here, we expect to see the
loading flash, and we expect to see the Boolean
load down in the console. And we do so the SDK
has successfully been wired up. And it's set up
a polling in the background. So we go to unleashed
now. And we change this gradual rollout to be
100%. That should be reflected, and we go back
here, we should be able to see that the new
components is being loaded, because this has been
put to true. The now the conditional render is
reloading the right component. So if we hit here,
we open the Chatbot. And we can interact with it.
And we can also go back to
unleash and turn this off again.
And that should propagate and remove the Chatbot.
Nice. So I never get tired of seeing that. Even
though this is just localhost. When you're doing
this in production, it just feels like magic. And
now we've seen how it behaves when you have that
0%. And when you have that 100%, which is what
we expect. It's either 100% on or 100% off.
But let's try changing the gradual rollout to
50%, for example. And we'll hit Save.
And let's go ahead and refresh this page.
And we'll refresh just a couple of times here.
Because we would expect the chatbot to turn up 50%
of the time, right, because that's
what we set the gradual rollout to,
but it seems like it doesn't. So there's
something going on here. Let's copy this URL.
And we'll open up a new incognito window. And
we didn't get it there. Let's try this again.
And not there either. So
maybe third time's a charm.
And not there either. So that's interesting,
because it is a 50% chance. And there we have it.
So here it turns up. And the reason that
it turns up here, and if we refresh this,
it's going to stay here. Because
we are using the session ID
to ensure that we get the same experience.
So if we take a look at this call here,
you can see that the session ID is sent as a
parameter to the proxy. And as long as you stay
within the same session, you will get the same
experience. Because we don't want this to change
just randomly, right, we want the users to have
the same experience even if they reload the page
in the same session. That's why in our
other tab, we don't get the Chatbot,
because we already received a version of the
site that does not have the Chatbot turned on.
And even though the percentage is set to 50%,
we are now in the category that will not receive
the feature. And this is quite useful, because we
want to be able to keep a consistency in the way
that the user experiences the site. Now, session
ID that's quite limiting because the user might
turn off their computer, they might go on their
phone, they might visit a friend's house and use
their computer and then the session ID can't
be used in order to determine whether or not
the user should get the same version because the
session ID will be different from time to time.
And maybe there's a way we can look at where
we can actually keep it consistent. Even If
the user changes their device, and to do that,
we need to take a look at the English context.
So, English context is used for a couple of
things. It's used for strategy, standardization.
It's used for stickiness. And it's also used
to pass properties to custom strategies if
you implement those. So there's a few fields here,
like dynamic context fields that you can populate.
And one is the user ID. Another is the session
ID. And then we have the remote address.
And finally, we have the properties, which is a
map that you can very can put anything you want.
Now, remember back to when we talked about the
architecture, we said that when the SDK does the
evaluation, it receives the configuration
from the unleash server. And then it takes
the context that it receives. And it merges the
two together, and makes a decision on whether or
not this is on or off. So to illustrate that,
we're going to take a look at the code here.
And this is the Node js SDK, which is
basically what the proxy builds upon,
it wraps around this SDK. And this here is
the is enabled call for a feature toggle.
So you received the feature toggle name. And
you can see we received the context as well.
And what is happening here is we're taking the
feature from the internal repository of the SDK.
So that means that the SDK has already fetched
the configuration from the unleash server.
And it will use that configuration together with
the context and make a decision on whether or not
this feature is enabled. And this is also why
we recommend self hosting the proxy because the
user data or context that you send from the
client application, that's going to be used,
as we just discussed, to evaluate the toggle in
the proxy. And that's where the data flow stops.
So the user data does not go to the Unleashed
API. So if you self host the proxy, you have 100%
control over your data. Alright, so now we've
seen a little bit about the unleash complex,
let's go ahead and implement this and see
if we can use that to get a consistent
experience for our users. So we'll open
up the unleash proxy client documentation.
And we'll scroll to the bottom and check
the documentation here for the context.
And it looks like we can take the use and least
context hook and get a function here. So that's
what we're going to do. If we open up our code,
we can add the use and which context here.
And we'll say Update context,
equals use unleash context.
And then we are going to add a use effect
here. So we'll add that to the Import up top.
And we'll say use effects.
And we only want this to happen on nouns.
And then we want to update the context
with a user ID. And let's call this user one
for now. And this should be enough for us to
be able to provide a steady experience
for the user regardless of the device.
Because if we have back to the Alisha instance,
and check out the gradual rollout strategy here,
you can see that we have the
stickiness set to default.
And the default actually checks for a user ID in
the context first, then the session ID. And if
it can't find either of those, it's going to be
random. And you can explicitly choose user ID or
session ID here. But the default is going to look
for first the user ID and then the session ID.
So this should be enough for us to get a sticky
experience. So let's check it out. If we go to
our application, and we open up the developer
tools, and we can now see that the costs that
are being sent to the proxy, include the user
ID here. So this means that no matter how many
windows, we open up, we should get
the same experience to remember
when we did this before, it was a 50% chance that
we would get another experience. But now you can
see that the experience is the same no matter
how many times I will open this new window.
Let's try one more time, just to make sure we
are completely sane. And we can see that we
still have the same result. Now, let's jump
back to the code. And notice that the value
use a one here is hard coded. Now, this doesn't
really make sense, because that means that every
single user that visits your site will use this
value to hash and get the same result, every time,
what you typically want to do is you want to get
this value from an API. And that's going to be a
unique identifier for each user. And this will
ensure that every user gets a different result.
Alright, so we've taken a look at the gradual
rollout strategy. And we've also been through
the unleash context. And now we can also take
a look at some of the other strategies that we
have available to us. So before we start, let's
go ahead and put the gradual rollout to serum.
And we can go ahead and add a user ID strategy.
Now, a user ID strategy is typically a strategy
you want to use while you're developing something,
because it will allow you to ask a set of user IDs
that will get access to the feature. So you could
have this behind a feature flag in production. And
you could give access to a specific set of users,
which could be the developers or maybe a product
manager, or a tester or another stakeholder in
the organization. So if we put in user one here,
and we add this, now, we will see that
the execution plan is updated. So 0%
of the user base is included, and will give access
to one user. So if we go back to the application,
now we can see that we have access to the
feature here. So we can go ahead and open up
the Chatbot again. And now we can do exactly
the same as we did with the gradual rollout,
we can go ahead and either remove this strategy
entirely. Or we could just remove the user.
And if we now head back to the application, now
we don't have access to the feature anymore. So
that's completely based on the values that are
sent into the context that we just discussed.
So since I have user one, as a value here, I
will get access to this feature if my user ID
is defined in the strategy. So if I go ahead and
go back to the strategy here and put user two,
that's not going to work, because my user ID is
user one. So if we go back to the application,
we can see that we don't have access here.
But if we go back to the strategy again,
and add our user ID, and hit save, you should be
able to see that the teacher now shows up again.
And we can once again open up and
interact with each other. Alright,
so now that you've seen how to use the user
ID strategy to give access to certain users,
let's jump back to the Unleashed instance. And
we'll have a look at the strategy is section here.
Because what's really cool is that you can
have as many strategies as you want. And as
long as the environment is on, they will all be
evaluated. And if any one of them return true
for the given context, then the feature
will be on for that user. So that means that
if you have a gradual rollout set to zero, like
we have here, then it will be on or no users.
But we will also go ahead and check the user
ID strategy. And since my user ID is user one,
and I passed that in, I still get access to
the feature. So every strategy is evaluated.
And that makes it really flexible. Because
you can add as many strategies as you want
that constraint on different properties. And
you can even create your own custom strategies
and provide the implementation in code so that
you can create strategies that don't really
exist in the system out of the box, but that you
need in the complex that you're operating in.
So if we open up the sidebar here, we can
take a look at the built in strategies.
And we've already been through two of them. And
the IP and host strategy work very similarly to
the user ID strategy. So if we add the IP
strategy, we need to provide an IP here.
And once we've added that, and we saved the
strategy, we can see that the execution plan
is updated. But now we need to take this IP, and
we need to add it to our code. So let's go ahead
and remove our user ID, because we want to see
that we don't have access to the feature anymore.
If we jump back to our application, now
we don't have access to the Chatbot.
But if we go ahead and take this IP
address, and we head back to the code,
now we can add a remote address property
here. And we put in the IP address.
And let's go back to the browser. And now we
once again have access via the remote address
strategy. So all of the strategies have been
evaluated. And this final one return true.
So we get access to the feature because our IP
address matches the value that is put in here.
Alright, and now we've gotten our feet a little
bit better with feature toggles. And we've
seen how we can use branches to target different
segments of the user base. So what I want to focus
on next is experimentation. And sometimes, as
developers, we want to develop different versions
of a feature, and try it out. So we can determine
which one performs better. And that's a process
that keeps the users close to us. And that's
important, because we don't want to just take
a feature and run with it and develop something
that we think is right, we want to continuously
validate that we're actually building something
that gives real value to our users. And in order
to do that experimentation, and a B testing can be
quite powerful tools that we can use to figure out
which one performs better. And I'm going to show
you how to do this in unleash. But before I do,
I just want to mention quickly how we think
about working with other services because
we don't have any built in analytics in release.
And one of the reasons for that is actually back
to our philosophy. Because we believe that
there's a lot of software being written today.
And there's a lot of great work that others
do. And, for example, analytics, you have great
providers that provide a world class analytics
experience. And we believe that it's our job to
make as many integration points and
provide as flexible as system as possible.
So that you can use the great work of
others, and combine services to gain a
better experience. So we're not really focusing
on implementing analytics in the traditional sense
when it comes to experimentation, we instead focus
on giving you the option of taking some provider
that you're probably already using today. And
pairing that with data from unleash. And then
you can send that off to your analytics provider
and do the necessary analysis on the data.
So with that said, let's jump into it and see how
we can do some A B testing with unleash. Okay,
so here we are back in the unleash application.
And we've done a little bit of cleanup on the
Chatbot pitch toggle. As you can see, we removed
some of the strategies that were here before. And
what we're left with is the gradual rollout
that's rolling out to 100% of our users.
So we're going to use this feature toggle and
set up an ad experiment. And in order to do that,
we'll need to learn about a new concept and
unleash old variants. So we'll navigate to
the variants tab. And we'll go ahead
and add a couple love variant a here
and then we'll add another one.
And now we basically have the setup that
we need. We still need to do some work on
the code side of things. But before we do, let's
try and understand the weight distribution here.
You can see that each variant has a weight
distribution of 50%. And this means that
if the percent of the year users that are visiting
our site and that get access to this feature
will get variant A, and 50% will get variant B.
So let's take a very concrete example and say we
have 100 users visiting, we have a gradual rollout
that says that everyone visiting will get access,
that means that 50 users will get variant A and
50 users will get variant B. But let's change the
strategy just to see how that affects the weight
distribution. So we'll change this now to 50%.
And we'll head back to the variance.
Now, let's take the same example. Again,
we have 100 users visiting our site, we only have
50% rollout. So that means that we only have 50
users that get access to the Chatbot feature.
And since we have a 5050 weight distribution,
that means that of those 50 users 25 users will
get variant A and 25 users will get varying B.
So it's all relative to the amount of people that
get access to the feature toggle. So you can think
of strategy's sort of like a gatekeeper that lets
people through or not. And then the variants can
be thought of as pathways that we send the people
that get through the gates, on after they are
led through. So currently, we have variant a and
variant B, which means that there are two possible
pathways for the people that are lit through. And
we could easily add more pathways if we wanted to.
But hopefully that makes sense. And we'll now
go ahead and implement the code side of this.
So before we jump to recode,
let's head back to the
strategies. And we'll make sure that we
set the gradual rollout back to 100%.
And with that, we can check that we
propagate this to the application.
And we do so let's head into the code now. And
we'll grab the use variant hook from the unleash
proxy client library. And then we'll do variants
equals use variant. And we'll put in the feature
toggle name. So with that, we can go ahead and
log this out here. And we'll open up the console.
And we can see here that B got the variant A,
which corresponds to the variant name that we
added for one of the variants. You see. Here,
we have the variant a here, so we automatically
got one of the variants that we defined.
Now, we also have the enabled true here,
which means that we don't really
need to use the US flag hook anymore,
because we get both of the data properties
in this object. So we'll go back to the code.
And we'll remove the enabled. And
then we'll say, aren't enabled here.
And we'll pass the variant as a prop
here to this app with chatbot component.
And let's accept it here. So what we
want to do now, based on this variance,
we are going to render a different welcome
message in the chat bot. So in order to do that,
let's create a new function inside of the
configuration here. And we will create a
config method which is going to take a
welcome message and it's going to return
the configuration that we put in here
but the initial message is going to be the welcome
message. So we'll export the complete function.
And then we'll head back to app
J S. And we will rename this
Okay, so let's remove the use flag here since
we're not using that anymore. And we'll scroll
down to our app with chatbot component where
we are accepted In the variant as a parameter,
now we're gonna do config equals yet conflict.
And then we want to paste in the message here.
And I've already prepared that. So we skipped
some typing. But what we want to do is we want
to check the variant name, like we're doing here.
And if the variant name is variant A, then we
want to have this folk message. Otherwise,
we want to have this welcoming message.
So we'll hit Save. And we'll pass this into our
git config. And we are passing the config here.
So everything is as it should be. So with that,
we can go ahead and open up the browser again.
And you can see that we get the welcome
message here. And if we refresh,
and we open up the Chatbot. Again, there we
have the same message. So that's working fine.
So let's see if we can trigger this message here
as well, because right now we have been given
a variant. And that variant is not going to
change because we have passed in the User ID here.
And that will ensure that the variant is sticky
as well. So we'll get the same experience
whenever we open the website.
But what we could do in order to
trigger or force a change is we can take this
user ID here. And we can go back to our unleash
application. And inside of variant B, we can go
ahead and add an override. And you see here we
have a context field called User ID. Let's put our
user in there. And we'll hit Save. And you can see
now we have an override on this variant. If we
go back to our application now, and we refresh.
Now we can see that we have another message.
And that's in fact, the message that we
provided as an alternative. Cool. So here,
we use invariants, to change the messaging
in the chat bot when we launched it. But that's a
simple example. And if we take a look at the code,
all we're really doing is we're checking the
variant name, and then doing something based
on that. So here we're changing the text. But it
could easily be rendering a different component,
or changing something within another
component. It's really up to you,
and what your experiment entails and how you
want to go about it. But it's as flexible as
it needs to be to cover the use cases that you
could have. And here we only have two variants,
but you could easily have three or four or
five. And that's up to you and your your
now let's talk about analytics. I mentioned
briefly before that we prefer to defer to
world class analytics providers. In order to
allow you to integrate with providers that you
most likely are already using today,
I wanted to show you how we can use
unleash together with your analytics provider and
create a trail that makes it so that you can track
a given variant through your application. So I'm
going to show an example with Google Analytics.
And I've already installed the React
Google analytics package here. So
let's go ahead and initialize it. And then
we'll take a look at how we could do this.
So what we'll do is we'll import react
GA from react, da. And then we'll go
ahead and initialize it. So inside of our
application, we can put it in a use effect.
We initialize it with the following
parameters, and then this would be your
unique Google Account Key. Alright,
so let's see a few more changes.
First of all, we'll create a variable for our
user ID. And we'll put the user ID in here.
And then we will paste that in here. And
we'll replace the value here as well.
And then what we'll do is we'll
go down to our ackward Chatbot.
And we'll go ahead and add a use factor as well.
And we'll make it dependent on the variant.
And we'll see if variants
name and variant enabled.
Let's do react, da. And we'll use an event here.
And then we can send an event to Google Analytics,
you can see the label application loaded.
And let's go ahead and add the variants.
That's going to be the variant name.
And then we'll give it an action. This required
property, we'll say location loaded with a
with the variant name. And we'll
also want to give the user ID here.
That means we need to go up in our parent
component, we need to pass in the User ID here.
And we'll accept that as a parameter.
And now, I have the ability to send
an event to Google Analytics. And that event
includes the user ID and the variant name. And
that means now you have your baseline, because
you have the user ID, and you know that which
variant that user ID loaded up with. So if you're
tracking more actions on your sites, for example,
if you want the user to convert, or in this case,
let's say we wanted to check whether or not the
user is interacting with the Chatbot, based on
the message, we could go ahead and add more events
with the user ID and the variant name in other
places of the application where it makes sense.
And we know that the action has been taken by
the user with this variant, okay. So that's
the way we can track the user across the
application, if that's what you want to do.
Alright, so I want to show you a
little bit about the metrics as well,
because one of the coolest things about
feature toggles systems, you can see
the updates live. And you can see who is getting
access to what feature or how many people are
getting access to a feature. So when you wire up
the SDKs, and you put up the API key, you'll start
sending metrics based on the environment that that
API key is configured for. So I currently have a
script running that's calling against the API with
an API key that's enabled for development. And
we currently have the strategies set to 100%.
So we have the gradual rollout that to 100%. So
everyone who is asking against this API is getting
enabled back for this feature. So let's go ahead
and update this. We'll set the gradual rollout
to 50%. And we had back to our application. Now,
we're going to be able to see as this updates
that more and more people are getting denied
the access to the feature, and it's going to
creep back towards the 50% mark over time.
And that's how you can be sure that
when you're setting a gradual rollout,
or you're setting his strategy configuration
that you expect is going to be enabled for a
subset of your users, you could use the metrics
to verify that that is, in fact happening. And
now we can see that we're slowly making our
way towards the 50% mark. And more and more
of the users are asking for access towards the
API or getting denied, which is what we expect.
Right? So we talked about metrics a little bit.
And besides that, there are some other methods
for monitoring that you can do in Unleash. And
if you remember, we talked to a bar earlier about
technical depth. And we take it really seriously
because you have to be able to clean up your code
and remove feature flags as you go along to have
a sustainable workflow, and you're working with
pitch dollars. So I'm hearing the demo instance
because it has a lot more feature flags available.
And I want to show you the health dashboard that
we built, which is sort of a work in progress, but
We have an early version of it ready. And we can
add on to the project. And this is a demo instance
that anyone can log in and use. So there'll
be a lot of projects here and a lot of data.
Because it's kind of a sandbox that anyone can
use some trial unleash. So if we head over to
the health section here, you see we have a
health rating, and we have a toggle report.
And then we have all of the feature toggles
in this project down in the overview here.
And you get some information here, basically,
the name of the toggle when it was last seen,
which is when did we last register and SDK
asking for this feature toggle. And so it's
if it's never seen, then you've never connected up
in SDK and started to use this feature toggle. But
if you do have a value here, and then you know
that it's a base, since this last was in use,
which might indicate that it was used in a local
environment, and not in a production environments,
because if you're in production, you
would expect it to be continuously
asked for. And then you have like, you can see
some more information when it's created. And
there is an expired column, which basically, based
on the type of each table you create, we use some
internal data to calculate when it's expired.
And for release toggle, that's about 40 days.
Because that's what the research indicates that
should be the lifetime or life expectancy of
Tableau like that. So you can use this dashboard
to get an overview over toggles that might
be ripe for cleaning up, and it can help you
in the effort to clean up your troubles and
get rid of some of the technical depths.
Alright, that's it for the course. And I
want to thank you so much for tuning in giving
me the opportunity to explain this concept. And
I hope it's been a valuable lesson in terms of
understanding how to work with feature toggles,
and how we can use them to simplify your
workflow and run experiments within your code.
Now, if you're wondering where you can find on
leash, we're on social media, obviously, but the
most important part is the code that's on GitHub.
We are after all, an open source organization. And
you can go to the unleash repository, and you can
browse through all the code. And if you want to
contribute, there are opportunities for that as
well. If you have any other questions, you can
tune into our open Slack channel, or we'll
be happy to help you along if you want to get
started using feature toggles. Now, if you want
to know where you can reach me, I'm on Twitter
under at F Allsburg. Or you can find me at
my YouTube channel, which is called Frederick
Osbourne recording lessons here on YouTube. And
with that, I hope you have a really great day